[Music]
alright guys I don't know about you but
I really miss traveling but apparently
me as an American I cannot go to eat you
what why that official okay well not not
as of this moment like not a thousand
percent but I'm saying like there's
probably most likely that the u.s. is
not gonna make the final list of
countries of that will be allowed into
the EU is it cuz we're too nasty we're
we're gonna talk number one the most
we're following number one again why do
we have to be number one and everything
we do yeah
so as it right now there are more than
two point three million cases and upward
of a hundred and twenty thousand deaths
well I mean like more than any other
country in the world I don't I want to
go to Europe but then I don't like being
told I can't go to Europe nice I've been
there I mean you didn't go to the right
places tropical beaches I did too
and I really like even when I like
exploring a city I still kind of get mad
that I paid that much to not be at a
tropical beach and you been to the
Mediterranean I do want to go to the
Mediterranean it's like Greece yeah yeah
yeah I love Europe me too man there
every single year for work oh no but
like thank you but yeah just the idea
that like we can't go there because of
the [ __ ] that's going on man I'm I'm
embarrassed to you know I'm still
[ __ ] glad I'm American but you know
and proud but I'm embarrassed to be an
American during this timeframe man this
is crazy
that's ridiculous I'm never embarrassed
to be American they're [ __ ] losers
blocking us you're not getting this you
hear that Europe you missed out yep so
they're saying that I don't refuse you
you you your cat refused as we refused
Europe yeah that's the thing actually
it's kind of I get fired I quit no so
you guys remember in March when Trump
said that Europe was the epicenter or
like when Europe was the epicenter that
Trump ended up saying
like okay no Europeans can come to
America and he ended up infuriating
European leaders so some others getting
us back it sounds like it was really
immature that sounds really fair look at
our sky their numbers are bad you
shouldn't go there and vice versa play
with your toys so you can't play with
our toys I know it's not like that I was
just it's funnier totally it's it's
appropriate because at the time though
nobody understood the severity of things
you know I'm saying I was there when it
was severe it's like I can understand in
that timeframe but in this timeframes to
see the whole [ __ ] rest of the world
get their [ __ ] under control and for us
to like spike up to even crazier stats
than ever before it's like yeah the
whole world should look at America and
be like uh-huh no way don't don't bring
your [ __ ] up but weren't we kind of like
the last to get hit yeah so that makes
sense where they were so ahead of us so
then they are seeing like the chill and
there wasn't any testing as much testing
back then so we don't really know what
the numbers were for them cuz I thought
that as Wuhan was kind of like
stabilizing that's when Italy and they
lied about the numbers with everyone
true so you have the Klan was [ __ ]
with us I'm not denying that there's a
bunch of crazies like you know people
that are they're just like pissed off
about the mass stuff and quarantine and
like they're being unreasonable but
they're not the majority of Americans
right that's the media I just keep
telling them and I'm like stop you're
making it look great that's what they
get this is what I realize is like
Europeans and outside of America they
get the news of the shittiest people of
America they don't get like they get the
floor demands yes doing that they've
been showing are Jerry Springer over
there go look at Americans yeah although
we do have a lot of [ __ ] dumbasses
but it's a numbers game it's 300,300
thousand three hundred million people so
it's like there's gonna be a lot of
stupid in that
good million there's just a lot we also
got like a entitled stupid though you
know mean which is which is the
double-edged sword of democracy right
because like of course we don't want to
be in this like totalitarian Authority
and you know communists or whatever but
in all the all those other countries
because they have those kind of
governments in place when things like
leap endemic come into the entire nation
there's quicker easier control right and
it's like we don't have that so we have
this whole gray area of like the right
way and in the you know the states
making decisions like how did we be find
ourselves in position where like state
by state and county by county lock downs
were happening so like sometimes a
California you being in like quarantine
and then the next state over wasn't and
people could drive back and forth since
college or even the next city yeah like
what are we doing versus like if
everybody understood and if it took only
fourteen if everybody throw to shut the
[ __ ] up and actually quarantine for like
14 days or a month for real do you think
America has too much freedom then yeah
no not not not too much for them to less
dangerous to say yes very dangerous to
say but from a medical perspective
that's one of the things that goes
against us because there's people that
are going every one of those 50 stars
makes their own decision possibly 51
possibly at the word it makes sense like
if you if your country just got
stabilized like why would you invite
people that are still dealing with it to
your country I get that for sure yeah
too much freedom is too many opinions
and sometimes a lot of idiots should not
be making any rules I couldn't that be
like if we have a Surgeon General rights
and that guy come out that was what yeah
yeah I just shouldn't that guy come out
Beale I am the Surgeon General they
could be the the medical president of
the country and go hey everyone shut the
[ __ ] up I don't care if you're a left or
right right now it's my turn to make
some shots and everyone listens to me
like not about that saucy guy Fauci
folks
yes Anthony fallacy what's his position
he's the top doctor he's the top guy
that was actually the pandemic task
force
you know what about the Surgeon General
work I don't even know who that guy is
he where a general he worth of general
how are doctors supposed to work
generals outfit no he's got a doctor's
outfit but with like medals and stuff
because you know there's a surgeon
general's warning on certain things yeah
all the time to just it's it's legit
like position it's like being Secretary
of State so I'm like why how come this
[ __ ] doesn't come out
he does he does yes you see he was well
the thing that I did register cuz he's a
black guy he was saying like you know
that's pretty cool that like I could
tell my kids like it could be anything
he could be a surgeon general just like
me that's not the [ __ ] we need to hear
nothing registered to me about him not
about the national press briefing I'm
glad my kids could be a surgeon general
one day it's like man I wish that day
was playing right now but oh well I want
to hear some medical advisors I'm sure
he gave it I just didn't register it on
TV
authority Falls to like everybody else
so like these people are literally in
front of the nation saying this is what
should be done you should do this Union
the social distance where mass blah blah
but if you can't get in force or people
just feel like they end up enforcing
that then what else can they enforce and
then next thing you know we have no
freedom but that's why it's this the
Surgeon General telling us right so we
go okay because like so that's like
saying it sort of having billets is that
person hold responsibility in that field
right so if the [ __ ] I don't know the
smokey the bear comes out and go don't
start foolish spires and he's the
authority figure for fires cartoon
character for Coronas mary's to listen
to jerome adams by the way okay general
mattis just one smoky bear's name is
Jerome the Surgeon General dr. Jerome
being one guy I didn't I thought I
didn't know just one guy wrote all the
cigarette this clear yeah I don't know
if one guy writes it but I believe it is
it's like Secretary of State or whatever
right I believe dr. Jerome he's a guy
that tells everyone if you're pregnant
don't smoke I did not know it's just one
guy yeah like if he comes out he's not
wearing a surgeon's outfit and tells us
these things then I I don't think people
would take it like all he's taking away
our American freedoms this is medically
what he wants us to do what do you say
cuz when I googled Surgeon General and I
click on use the top headlines 101 says
Surgeon General Jerome Adams some places
reopened too early the next one says
wants coronavirus shaming to stop he's
saying the wrong generalized Surgeon
General Mike Wright all the states have
control right there's even state Surgeon
General's Florida's Surgeon General
speaking up first of all look there are
moments in history right for example
like the president the commander in
chief has a right for things like
Marshal Law right in almost where he
take authority over the state's mob all
right there should be something like
medical what I'm saying medical martial
law or some [ __ ] yeah because like look
this this is people are [ __ ] trying
to argue with like science and stats
like that that's not really a subjective
concept sometimes conflicting
information so even from the CDC and
there are doctors and scientists and
people that can together yeah that are
not agreeing with it do have you done
that thing side note um where you put I
think of any number any number and you
put it put in that number and then put
new cases don't even put coronavirus or
anything just put any number and then
new cases watch nine new cases okay no
no yeah
Surgeon General comes out and says
Colorado I new cases what about it
it says the top thing that says 621 new
Kovan 19 cases statewide nine new cases
in Valley
something that they'll be no matter what
there'll be an article on whatever
number you put in for new cases yeah
there is
yeah Westmoreland County reports me 573
573 new cases um Singapore reports 573
new cases what what does that mean no
reports 573 new confirmed cases 6302
okay six thousand three hundred and two
new cases
no nothing Oh
maybe has to be under a thousand three
digits three digits I believe it's three
digits or less how about three hundred
thirty three new cases three three I'm
gonna test every [ __ ] number
rotavirus three three three new cases in
Italy try it try 1051 okay just to see
if it was a four-digit number uh yeah it
has to be under a thousand guys three
religious Wes it says 25 new cases
county total at 1051 this is a
conspiracy
Indonesia reports 1051 you covered 19
cases where's the Surgeon General we
need when we need them yeah there's got
to be some sort of like real ethical law
force man like yeah it's someone that
just comes out and like gives us some
leadership and tells us what to do is
season that promise and we'll [ __ ] he is
to him I never heard of this why don't
we do they should remember it remember
his whole team his whole team right was
like directly working with the president
and the Trump administration in order to
figure this whole thing out so they so
they say and everything that like Trump
was saying versus what they're saying it
was like damn near completely opposite
you already know Trump into press
briefings [ __ ] cannibalizing their
entire scene what if he knows some [ __ ]
he's trying to protect the people he's
doing the opposite cuz like the Dom to
kill Americans and Trump is like don't
listen I think that's a very bold
concept uh obviously I'll be interesting
to know where that thought realm comes
all trans I would be more quick to and
willing to listen to a medical
professional about this versus somebody
else well I'm not listening to the World
Health Organization cuz big for some
reason other and I against that wouldn't
you say Taiwan all the time because the
China own
[Music]
[Music]